ce soir là notre invité c'était pierre
et ex tient le texte qui a bien voulu se
prêter au jeu de la caméra invisible et
pendant la préparation de l'interview
qui allait avoir les pierre tchernia
il s'est simplement penché à son oreille
et lui a dit sois gentil de parler très
fort avec moi car j'ai en ce moment des
ennuis avec mes oreilles quelle
situation pour un animateur de jeu
j'ai le plaisir de vous dire que notre
invité c'est justement pierre et texte
qui va nous présenter dans quelques
jours son dernier film qui s'appelle le
grand amour non il n'est pas encore sans
humoristes on va le voir d'ici quelques
jours alain va le voir d'ici quelques
jours
c'est un film un peu différent de ce que
vous avez fait jusqu'à présent par par
la narration par le style de narration
vous avez adopté
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire du grand amour
mais a aussi je vous prie de m'excuser
j'ai pas très bien compris votre
question vous m'avez dit non je dis que
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir le grand
amour qui est un film qui m'a beaucoup
plu pas par sa tendresse par son humour
et qui est un film un peu différent de
ce que vous avez pu faire avant par le
style de sa narration ici
je crois que c'est une petite plaisanté
point caméra visite excuses des courtes
et c'est dommage il